avant la foule de la fête de l'humanité
levé le poing déterminé mobiliser de
toutes ses forces pour chasser du
pouvoir cette droite haineuse attisant
le racisme et les tensions
internationales pressurant les classes
populaires en bonvalet seller du capital
et des puissants mais ça c'était avant
c'était qu'il y a juste un an jour pour
jour
maintenant vous lever le poing déterminé
mobilisés et rassembleur pour conquérir
de nouveaux droits pour de nouvelles
solidarités pour construire le
changement tant attendu auquel de toutes
vos forces
vous avez contribué quelle différence
avec l'année dernière
quel soulagement mais d'une année sur
l'autre
notre détermination reste intacte
je peux vous annoncer que vous avez été
cette année encore plus nombreux à la
fête que l'an passé
on lâche rien
et comme l'a si bien chanté ici même
hier soir l'immense patti smith
ici le peuple prend le pouvoir
merci à vous d'avoir participé si
nombreux à cette grande fête
désespérance nouvelle à ce rassemblement
du partage de la fraternité de
l'émancipation humaine
merci à chacune et chacun d'entre vous
pour votre engagement
quelle qu'en soit la forme merci pour
votre humanité
votre diversité est notre force à vous
les jeunes qui rendait la fed si belle
et si joyeuse vous qui avez communier
tous ensemble dans la fraternité dans
les concerts et les débats nous disant
ce n'est qu'un début et je vous pose la
question si cette fête devait être le
point de départ d'un large front citoyen
populaire pour mener la guerre à
l'austérité au chômage pour construire
un nouvel avenir de justice de liberté
de paix ce serait la meilleure chose qui
puisse arriver car il n'y aura pas de
changement véritable
sans vous sans changer le rapport des
forces
sans votre mobilisation unitaire notre
fête aura été à l'unisson des grandes
manifestations populaires qui ont eu
lieu en belgique jeudi au portugal et en
espagne hier avec un million de
manifestants à madrid
hessel est celle qui se prépare en
italie en roumanie au royaume uni en
allemagne à l'unisson le 9 octobre de la
journée européenne des syndicats à
laquelle appellent la cgt à l'unisson de
la grande marche pour obtenir que le
peuple soit consulté sur le nouveau
traité européen
oui nous sommes à l'unisson de tous les
indignés du monde
tous ensemble on ne lâche rien nous
venons d'entendre les témoignages
émouvants de combattants de la liberté
pour la justice la solidarité et la paix
merci à vous chers barbara hendricks
pour votre engagement aux côtés des
réfugiés du nord mali merci à toi fadoua
soient assurés de notre détermination à
obtenir la libération de ton mari marwan
barghouti et de tous les prisonniers
palestiniens
oui liberté pour bar one liberté pour
les palestiniens emprisonnés dans les
cachots israélien avec le silence
complice des grandes puissances
assez de cette injustice
aux côtés de celui d'israël le peuple
palestinien a le droit de disposer d'un
état la paix et la sécurité dans cette
région et dans le monde ont besoin qu'il
soit reconnu dans les frontières de 1967
avec jérusalem est comme capitale
prenons ensemble ici l'engagement comme
vient de le dire fadoua tout à l'heure
de pouvoir fêter ici très bientôt
cette victoire de la justice et du droit
international
mon cheikh salah je sais que cet
engagement qui ira droit au coeur
l'an dernier je prenais ici devant vous
ce lui de voir
salah hamouri à nos côtés et bien grâce
à l'art nous sommes fiers de compter
parmi nous
non il ne faut rien lâcher avec vous
barbara fadoua salah avec tous les
progressistes et les démocrates des
printemps arabes
les peuples d'europe contre l'austérité
tous les jeunes en lutte pour leurs
droits les salariés les indignés avec
tous ceux qui se battent et ceux qui
combattent
ne lâchant rien ces femmes et hommes qui
mènent dans les pays arabes depuis des
mois au péril de leur vie
ce formidable combat pour la démocratie
la justice
nous le soutenons à tous nous exprimons
notre solidarité
la fête c'est la fraternité l'amitié
entre les peuples
mais chers amis on ne peut détourner le
regard de la véritable tragédie en cours
en ce moment en syrie le dictateur
bachar el-assad pour se maintenir au
pouvoir va jusqu à massacrer son peuple
cela suffit à ces deux morts nous
soutenons les forces progressistes qui
lutte pour imposer l'arrêt des armes
instauré la démocratie et la
souveraineté du peuple syrien
les répercussions de ce drame atteignent
désormais le liban créé de graves
tensions avec la turquie l'afghanistan
et l'irak sont à feu et à sang entre
israël et l'iran
la guerre menace nous ne pouvons
regarder ce chant de guerre sans rien
dire sans rien faire il faut crier
il faut dénoncer apporter concrètement
son soutien et ensemble à travers la
planète
construisant la grande chaîne pour un
bond sans âme et sans guerre ce n'est
pas une utopie c'est notre combat
dans de nombreux stands s'est exprimée
cette solidarité active permettez moi de
dire que nous réfutons et nous
condamnons avec la dernière énergie
toute provocation comme celle de cet
insupportable film politique d'un
intégriste israélien
diffusée depuis les etats-unis sur
internet qui constitue une insulte à pau
minable contre une religion l'islam et
les musulmans
mais nous condamnons tout autant tous
d'utilisation de cette provocation pour
semer le chaos
détruire des ambassades tuer des
diplomates elles n'aboutissent en fait
qu'à détourner le regard de l'essentiel
le combat pour l'accès à la liberté et
au mieux-être
oui chers amis notre solidarité
internationaliste ne saurait donc se
relâcher bien au contraire
chers amis toutes et tous ici nous
voulons que cette fête de l'humanité
soit un accélérateur du changement après
dix ans de droite au pouvoir
nous avons en avril en mai et en juin
dernier
renvoyer le président des riches au cap
il était grand temps sa trace
son terrible héritage sont encore là à
l'opposé de certains journaux et de
certains commentateurs bien pensants
nous nous n'écrivons pas et nous ne
crions pas sarkozy revient non rester là
où vous êtes votre règne restera dans
l'histoire comme une des périodes les
plus sombres qu'ait connu le monde du
travail et de la création
vous avez la mine et les droits sociaux
les libertés démocratiques bafoué les
valeurs d'égalité de tolérance injecter
les meneurs de la division de la
xénophobie et du racisme mise à mal
l'honneur de la france
sa grandeur sa vocation l'originalité de
sa voix dans le monde
déployer des efforts pour nous mettre à
genoux pour que notre voisin notre
collègue de travail deviennent notre
ennemi vous avez été jusqu'à vous
camouflé en défenseur du peuple en
empruntant sans jamais vous passez le
nez les voies nauséabond de l'extrême
droite haineuse et raciste
non nous ne regrettons pas le sarkozysme
et et nous ne voulons pas plus que ses
12 apôtres copé fillon le maire bertrand
dhainaut hortefeux estrosi
quand hugo morizet à tara est utile
quand ils reviennent on n'avait jamais
vu je dis bien jamais vu après une
victoire de la gauche la droite
l'extrême droite les marchés financiers
les institutions européennes se coaliser
à ce point se mobiliser avec une telle
rapidité et avec un tel acharnement
contre la moindre des réformes
progressistes qui était annoncé
c'est dire que l'enjeu pour les classes
dominantes est décisif il leur faut avec
acharnement combat qu'est à pied tout
choix de gauche et il ne lésine pas sur
les moyens
en 1981 rappelez-vous les mêmes avait
prédit les chats russe sur la place de
la concorde
cette fois on voit de grands patrons
comme celui de psa ou celui du nil vers
menacé des travailleurs et des ministres
de quitter la france
et on a vu dimanche dernier la quatrième
fortune mondiale l'empereur du luxe qui
a profité de lassus
du travail et du savoir faire de ces
ouvrières de ces ouvriers qui a utilisé
tous les équipements publics qui a
profité de l'état pour exporter et faire
fortune
oui on a vu ce monsieur bernard arnault
choisir la nationalité belge
à
on
et est ce monsieur ce monsieur voudrait
nous faire pleurer alors qu'il gagne
plus d'un smic
à chaque heure qui passe qu'il a
accumulé une fortune de 32 milliards
d'euros mais rassurez vous monsieur
arnault il ne sera pas sur la paille
il ne bougera pas sous les ponts
si une toute petite taxation
supplémentaire et fleurs sans gros
compte en banque
quelle insulte qu'elle insu que d'oser
se lamenter sur son sort de réfugiés
fiscale caen 16 millions de personnes
finissent le mois avec moins de 10 euros
prêts et que des centaines de milliers
de travailleurs sont aujourd'hui même
menacé d'être privés de leur travail
mais c'est d'ailleurs bien là tout le
problème
c'est bien parce que l'argent s'accumule
entre les mains de quelques-uns et va se
réfugier dans les paradis fiscaux
cochettes les travailleurs à la rue
comme des éponges pour ne plus voir cela
une majorité de françaises et de
français ont choisi la gauche en mai et
juin derniers être fidèle à leur choix
c'est répondre à leurs demandes de
justice oui il faut maintenant sans
attendre décider des réformes
structurelles progressive pour le
partage des richesses oui il faut
augmenter les impôts sur la fortune et
sur le capital au même niveau que les
prélèvements sur le travail
oui face à l'exceptionnelle mobilisation
des puissants il nous faut aujourd'hui
toutes et tous en sens opposé un large
front du peuple
un nouveau front populaire pour des
changements nécessaires entre dans la
vie de tous les jours partout et pour
tous
de premiers pas ont été accomplis par le
nouveau gouvernement
nous ne les sous-estiment ans pas plus
qu'ils apportent du mieux-être et que
nous y avons pris tout notre part au
parlement avec le groupe du front de
gauche présidé par mon ami andré
chassaigne je pense à la fin du bouclier
fiscal à l'augmentation de la prime de
rentrée scolaire aux mesures d'urgence
dans certaines écoles à l'abrogation de
la tva sociale à l'encadrement des
loyers au durcissement de la loi pour la
construction de logements sociaux au
retour à un apport à un impôt sur la
fortune de plein exercice à la création
d'emplois d'avenir par l'assemblée
nationale
il y a trois jours d'autres mesures ont
été annoncées comme la construction de
150 mille logements sociaux leur tour un
taux réduit de tva pour les livres mais
aussi mais aussi beaucoup moins positif
le maintien de celui consenti aux
restaurateurs en réponse à leur
mobilisation
mais on ne peut pas accepter que le smic
les prestations et les minima sociaux
mais pas été augmentée si cela va si mal
en france et en europe
ce n'est pas parce que les salaires sont
trop élevés mais c'est le contraire
c'est parce qu'ils sont insuffisants
le président de la république a fixé
dimanche le cap de l'inversion de la
courbe du chômage très bien ce cap nous
voulons contribuer à ce qu'il soit
atteint parce qu'il est ambitieux et
nécessaire
ambitieux parce que l'ultra droite
laisse un héritage catastrophique
tous les jours se révèlent des plans de
licenciements qui ont été soigneusement
mis sous le tapis par sarkozy et ses
amis à la tête des entreprises
c'est indispensable
c'est indispensable parce qu'un pays n'a
plus d'avenir
quand il est rongé jour après jour par
la gangrène du chômage quand il laisse
sacrifier son industrie et son
agriculture
l'avenir c'est d'inventer ensemble un
nouveau projet industriel et agricole
deux grands services publics en lien
avec l'indispensable métamorphose
écologique c'est nécessaire car nous
n'en pouvons plus de ces vies brisées de
tous ces jeunes pour lesquels trouver un
emploi est une véritable galère assez de
mépris des jeunes à qui un jour ont dit
vous êtes trop jeune pas expérimenté pas
qualifiés à nos dons leur dit vous êtes
trop vieux trop qualifiés et dans le
secret des bureaux
ils sont suspectés par leur nom leur
domicile ou la couleur de leur peau
les prétextes ne manquent pas eh bien il
faut en finir avec cela
oui nous soutiendrons la mise en place
des emplois jeunes et nous fondons
désespoir dans le dispositif
un jeune embauché en contrat à durée
indéterminée avec un senior maintenus en
activité et nous sommes convaincus que
les syndicats les salariés les élus
locaux les parlementaires de gauche et
du front de gauche feront le nécessaire
aux côtés des intéressés pour améliorer
tout ce qui doit l'être que le
gouvernement se fixe comme priorité la
même que celle qu'exprime nos
concitoyens est une très bonne chose
mais franchement
ne nous racontons pas d'histoires à quoi
servirait de créer 150 mille emplois
d'avenir
si par ailleurs notre industrie notre
agriculture
nos services publics continuer de perdre
chaque jour leur sens avec près d'un
demi million de suppressions d'emplois
le président de la république nous dit
maintenant que la crise est très grave
certes nous le savions
et lui aussi depuis bien longtemps
elle est grave la crise et elle est
chaque jour un peu plus graves
à quelques pas d'ici au bourget le
candidat françois hollande avec fougue
et conviction avait stigmatisé la cause
principale de cette crise d'une
profondeur exceptionnelle
l'ennemi c'est la finance avait il lancé
sous les applaudissements de la foule
mais sous nos applaudissements aussi
mais ça c'était avant
aujourd'hui le président ne le dit plus
plus que jamais nous nous continuons de
penser que c'est ennemi invisible doit
être mis à la raison
il lui faut lui limer les dents et fils
et lui nécessaire lui casser à bras de
bras une jambe de jambes
d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs entre nous soit dit entre
nous soit dit c'est cela est de gauche
dans le pays de la nuit du 4 août 1789
et de l'abolition des privilèges avoué
qu'il serait paradoxal qu'un
gouvernement socialiste écologistes
tiennent plus compte aujourd'hui de ceux
qui l'ont combattu que de ceux qui l'ont
élu
c'est à dire les salariés les jeunes
alors oui ensemble
unissons-nous et mobilisons nous pour
faire entendre notre voix
mobilisons nous pour modifier le rapport
des forces en va s' ils font ce qu'il
faut pour que ce soit au bénéfice des
privilégiés parce qu'ils savent qu'un
rapport de force n'est pas
définitivement coulé dans le marbre par
le résultat d'une élection mais ce qui
est possible pour eux l'est tout autant
pour nous pour vous pour les
accélérateurs du changement pour le
faire me direz vous mais il y à des
majorités à l'assemblée nationale au
sénat dans les régions dans les
départements et dans de nombreuses
villes et villages
oui c'est vrai parfaitement vrai mais il
manque l'essentiel l'engagement actif de
nos concitoyens leur application bref
leur mobilisation large rassembleuse
unitaire l'indispensable loi instituant
un moratoire sur tous les plans de
licenciements est à ce prix
elle permettra que soient réunies des
tables rondes qui au cas par cas
examineront dans le détail les
situations et les solutions pour
préserver le travail et l'emploi
représentants des salariés responsables
d'entreprises élus dirigeants de banques
et organismes de crédit représentant de
l'état auront la responsabilité d'y
parvenir c'est possible à condition de
partir de deux idées simples
ce n'est pas le travail qui coûte cher
c'est le chômage qui coûte cher
ce ne sont pas les cotisations sociales
qui étrangle les grandes entreprises
mais la charge que représente le coût
énorme des frais financiers qu'elle
verse aux banques et aux organismes de
crédit ainsi que les énormes dividendes
aux actionnaires
voilà voilà l'origine de bien des drames
économiques et sociaux de la période
fini son sens avec l'économie des
rentiers réinventant la belle société du
travail intéressant correctement
rémunérés et de l'innovation
si la banque d'investissement qui est
prévu et est accompagné d'un combat pour
changer la banque centrale européenne de
la création d'un pôle public bancaire de
contrôle de l'utilisation de l'argent et
des prêts alors oui un pas important
serait franchie pour rogner les crocs
des rapaces de la finance
et si cela ne suffisait pas je le dis
franchement il faudrait nationaliser
débats pour se donner les moyens de
relancer l'économie
ainsi l'argent pourrait enfin servir à
une réindustrialisation modern
écologique et au développement des
services publics des outils nouveaux
seraient ainsi créés en faveur du
travail en faveur d'une sécurité du
travail de l'emploi
combiné avec la formation et la
recherche une marche serait franchie
pour aller faire la suppression du
chômage cela à cela toi aussi contribué
une loi interdisant les licenciements
boursiers
et comme il faut mieux toujours prévenir
que guérir pour qu'on ne puisse plus
répandent au salarié de psa de doux de
fralib ou de sodimédical et encore
d'autres à ce qui vous arrive est
terrible et révoltant même mais nous ne
pouvons plus rien c'est trop tard eh
bien nous disons une nouvelle grande loi
doit être votée accordant des droits et
des pouvoirs nouveaux d'intervention aux
salariés dans la gestion même de leur
entreprise
et dans l'immédiat la gauche doit
produire un acte fort donné un signal
net pour le changement du rapport des
forces
elle doit proposer voter comme le
propose mes amis du front de gauche
présidé par andré chassaigne une loi
effaçant toutes les sanctions infligées
aux délégués syndicaux dans l'exercice
de leur mandat et leur réintégration
dans leurs postes de travail
autre signe à donner vite très vite
appliquons réellement l'égalité hommes
femmes au travail régulariser
régulariser tous les travailleurs sans
papiers et votons et vos dons
la loi promise pour le droit de vote des
étrangers
et si les capitulards ne veulent pas
maintenir la production
et bien qu'on institue un droit de
réquisition permettant aux salariés de
reprendre leur entreprise
oui chers amis nous allons entreprise
par entreprise ville par ville
département par département prendre
toute notre part dans la véritable
guerre que nous allons déclencher contre
le chômage et la précarité
partout nous allons jouer notre rôle d'
accélérateur du recul du chômage et de
la précarité et nous allons le faire
en opposant jamais la lutte pour
l'emploi de celle de l'amélioration du
pouvoir d'achat
les deux vont de pair facile à
comprendre
permettre à nos concitoyens de vivre
mieux c'est leur permet d'acheter ce
dont ils ont besoin qu'il faudra
produire en créant du travail
supplémentaire et de l'emploi sert le
contraire imposer l'austérité aboutit au
résultat inverse du chômage en plus et
au final la récession qui la minent le
pouvoir d'achat des populations les
ressources de l'état et de la sécurité
sociale les possibilités
d'investissements productifs dans les
entreprises partout où le remède de la
rigueur et de l'austérité s'applique la
crise continuent et s'aggravent
nous sommes d'ailleurs de moins en moins
seul à le dire et c'est tant mieux
ce n'est donc pas parce qu'il ya une
crise qu'il faut imposer l'austérité
c'est le contraire c'est parce que
partout on applique l'austérité et les
privations que la crise s'aggrave
il faut donc
il faut donc inverser cette logique et
inventer un nouveau système de
répartition des richesses une autre
manière de les produire et de les
consommer justice sociale obsession
environnementale et transition
écologique vont de pair ce sont les
facettes du nouveau monde à construire
l'après capitalisme
le bond de l'humain d'abord
nous continuons de proposer comme l'a si
bien fait jean luc mélenchon dans la
campagne aux élections présidentielles
et le front de gauche dans celle des
élections législatives d'augmenter les
petits et moyens salaires les retraites
et les minima sociaux de 300 euros
en progressant vers la justice fiscale
et la justice sociale en faisant
contribuer les revenus du capital au
financement de la sécurité sociale
évidemment nous entendons race et m'ont
déjà les cris d'orfraie petit monde des
beaux quartiers et des salons dorés des
multinationales en vérité tél harpagon
dans l'avare ils pensent m'a cassé
m'agaçait on m'a volé ma cassette et
messieurs les puissants c'est le moment
votre cassette leur est venue de
l'ouvrir et de la partager
celle de vos profits comme on dit vidant
que vos comptes à l'étranger et dans les
paradis fiscaux pour la préserver vous
nous répéter depuis trente ans que les
profits d'aujourd'hui ferait les emplois
de demain mais plus vos profits ont
augmenté plus le chômage a explosé
vous aviez dit supprimé l'autorisation
administrative de licenciement et nous
créerons des emplois mais elle a été
depuis bien longtemps et vous ne cessez
de jeter les travailleurs et les
travailleuses à la rue comme de
vulgaires ces pages vous avez dit
supprimer la taxe professionnelle et
vous verrez elle a été supprimée mais on
n'a jamais rien vu venir
et aujourd'hui les mêmes nous assène la
crise est terrible serrez vous la
ceinture en faisons des sacrifices pour
supprimer la dette et demain tout ira
mieux mais ils disent la tête mais moi
et peut-être vous nous entendons matin
sept cars la dette
vous l'avez fabriquer vous-même en
abaissant les impôts sur la fortune un
capital en ouvrant la cage aux vampires
de la finance qui suce les économies des
entreprises et des états qui vole le
résultat du travail avec des taux
d'intérêt usuraires
rendez vous compte que le paiement de
ces intérêts est maintenant le deuxième
budget de l'état plus que celui de
l'éducation nationale
voilà ce qu'il faut avoir le courage de
changer radicalement pour contribuer à
les mettre au pas messieurs jean marc
ayrault et françois rolland vous couriez
compter sur nous parce qu'affronter le
monde des puissants et de la finance ça
ça nous connaît encore encore
conviendrait-il monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre que vous
produisiez des actes qui montrent que
vous en avez l'intention je vous le dis
sans animosité avec la plus grande
franchise dans un esprit constructif et
unitaire pour l'heure vous n'en prenez
pas de chemin vous avez annoncé un plan
de réduction des crédits utiles d'une
dizaine de milliards cela supprimera des
emplois et affectera la qualité des
services publics
vous avez annoncé la même somme en
augmentation des impôts des particuliers
mais là où le bât blesse c'est que
contrairement à vos engagements
ce ne sont pas les seuls au contribuable
qui seront touchés ce n'est bon ni pour
la confiance ni pour la relance de
l'activité de l'emploi
nous avons bien entendu aussi la part
qui revient aux entreprises aux hauts
revenus et aux détenteurs de capitaux
mais comprenez bien que nous allons vous
inciter à aller plus avant dans cette
direction plutôt que d'envisager une
augmentation de la contribution sociale
généralisée
nous ne disons pas au nom de je ne sais
quel fixation idéologique mais parce
qu'il est un jeu
co 3 cas ce soit les salariés les
retraités qui fournissent le gros de
cette cg nous vous faisons la sujétion
de regarder du côté de la rampe du
capital qui elles continuent d'être
exonérés de participation au financement
de la protection sociale
le faire ça porte un nom annonce simple
la justice alors que l'enjeu est un des
plus importants de notre époque
vous ne devriez pas envisager d'associer
cotisations supplémentaires et écologie
comment voulez vous avec cette amère
potion gagner la mobilisation de toute
la société à la réussite de la
transition écologique
regardez plutôt du côté des gros
pollueurs cela ce sont des meilleurs
tout trouvé et ne commençait pas non
plus à mettre en avant les contraintes
économiques alors que cette transition
recèle deux grosses potentialités
d'activité et d'emploi tous les
commentateurs ont remarqué cette chose
dimanche dernier c'est que le chef de
l'état avait soigneusement évité de
parler de l'europe
l'interprétation de ce silence est
simple françois hollande ne veut pas que
se fasse une connexion entre ce choc
fiscal qu'il a annoncé et le nouveau
traité européen ce texte pourtant co
écrit par monsieur sarkozy et madame
merkel
c'est l'écriture c'est l'écriture noir
sur blanc de ce qui a été imposée au
peuple grec
cela ressemble à une ordonnance mais
c'est une ordonnance qui tue le malade
c'est grave et cela ne doit surtout pas
être banalisé quand vous entendez
réduction des déficits
il faut comprendre baisse des dépenses
sociales et publiques
voilà ce qu'exige ce texte qu'il
faudrait transféré dans notre
constitution mais il est encore plus
grave et plus inquiétant que cela en
effet il donne les pleins pouvoirs à une
instance non élu la commission de
bruxelles pour décider des budgets des
nations est surveillé que les états
réduisent bien les crédits pour
l'hôpital
le logement l'école la pause les
transports la sécurité sociale les
retraites et aussi ceux des
collectivités locales
oui la perte de la souveraineté des
décisions du parlement se combinerait à
la perte de la souveraineté populaire
la démocratie en prendrait un sérieux
coup mais ce traité ne se contente pas
de cela puisqu'il a un pauvre des contre
réformes des droits sociaux et
économiques des droits du travail
voilà pourquoi on en parle depuis
quelques jours de flexibiliser encore
plus le travail c'est à dire en fait de
le précarisés de casser le contrat à
durée interdit indéterminée nous ne
l'accepterons pas il y a donc et il ya
donc un lien direct entre la politique
qui est proposé et ce nouveau traité
européen
une mobilisation de grande ampleur
sera nécessaire pour briser cette
camisole de pense nous voulons la
construire pour empêcher ce coup d'état
froid et nous voulons la construire au
nom même de l'engagement de françois
hollande de renégocier ce texte nous
demandons qu'il soit rendu public et
qu'il fasse l'objet d'un débat citoyen
sanctionnée par une consultation
populaire
oui au nom même de la réussite du
changement
nous réclamons à référendum
et dans 15 jours nous le ferons en temps
avec de multiples associations forces
progressistes et syndicales lors d'une
grande marche dans paris
nous ne baissons pas les bras nous ne
lâchant rien nous mettons à la
disposition de nos concitoyens 2
millions d'exemplaires d'une édition
spéciale de l'humanité pour décrypter ce
texte et permettent à chacune et chacun
d'intervenir de partout de partout monde
l'exigence de refondation de la
construction européenne d'une europe des
peuples pour les peuples
c'est en paille nous allons la mener et
nous allons la gagner
chers amis notre fait
comme vous le voyez est celle du soleil
est celle de l'espoir
la fête à nul autre pareil ou une seule
ambition parcourt les allées les débats
et les concerts l'humain d'abord
ici toutes et tous ensemble
vous avez bien servir cette cause la
plus noble qui soit celle de l'intérêt
général contre la caste des oligarchies
financières
c'est du quotidien qui l'a popularise
l'humanité notre journal comme tous nos
amis du front de gauche qui sont dj avec
pierre laurent marie george buffet andré
chassaigne
patrick apel muller le directeur de la
rédaction de l'humanité et tous les
autres noms que cette volonté n'ont
qu'un objectif être utile et dès demain
nous vous proposons de rester connecté
utiliser l'humanité et l'humanité
dimanche pour décrypter l'actualité et
pour intervenir pour changer changer
maintenant c'est urgent en étant utile
pour ne pas rester spectateur pour agir
intervenir et se rassemble et nous
aiderons la gauche
nous aiderons le gouvernement à prendre
de bonnes décisions
oui oui que du nord au sud de l'est à
l'ouest de la france
nos concitoyens partout où ils se
trouvent se fassent entendre
construisons ensemble ce grand front
progressiste un grand front pour comme
l'a proposé mon ami pierre laurent hier
sur cette tête participer à une grande
oeuvre la renaissance de la france et de
l'europe
c'est urgent c'est dur j'en ai alors oui
le changement ce sera maintenant
quoi de plus efficace de plus unitaire
deux plus fidèles au choix majoritaire
des français
quoi de plus de 10 la la gauche toute
entière et à l'écologie
rien chers amis je vous propose que
notre séparation soit de courte durée
dans quinze jours le 30 septembre
nous nous retrouverons je l'espère
encore plus nombreux dans cette grande
marche de nation à place d'italie pour
que tous ensemble tous nos concitoyens
obtiennent le droit qui conditionne tous
les autres le droit de choisir leur
avenir
chers amis on ne lâche rien
la peau
ces feux sont abraham foulée star
le mont de marsan je ne savais pas
c'est
ono
et
deux ans
à
c'est
hélas
bon pour nous